[Music]
in mine reading news submitted by y TF u
Lyon scientists have developed a brain
implant that can read people's mind a
man invented this to figure out the
brain of a woman I feel like as a woman
we are mind reader's right what am I
thinking right now I feel like your
emotional readers okay no I really am
though I'm like an emotional ninja yeah
I am animes feel what we think in yeah
what's David thinking David are feeling
[Laughter]
take the words out of my mouth I mean
that's straightforward though it's a
food he's usually like food sex or money
right isn't that like and then
occasionally like sex might filter
through yeah food will come in knock
that [ __ ] out how do you videogame
don't play games
really I don't play games never smoke
the cigarette in your life ever
what about drugs I mean I did weed to
help me sleep okay that's okay what
about drinking
oh I drink a lot that's right my dad
forgot about the summaries I don't think
drink is a drug because it's such a
cultural thing for me like cream you'll
drink all the time yeah it's water yeah
but I don't have alcohol my house but if
I go out I'm going just don't drive
alright so a team at the University of
California San Francisco says that
they've developed a brain implant that
can read people's minds and turn their
thoughts into speech so I really do this
explain a brain implant yes well you put
it in my mind and then now I can say
what I'm thinking cuz I can already do
that no so this is meant for people that
can't communicate I can't have form
speech Oh as I say like Oh me I can see
this yeah
that would have been helpful yes this is
for people that have like they have loss
of speech like motor neuron disease
brain injuries throat cancer some types
of stroke ain't something to sour so
what happens here is that there's this
electrode mouth cast on Bobby that's a
crazy injury
yes it's implanted in the brain and it
picks up electrical signals that
maneuver the lips tongue voice box and
jaw Wow it like picks up those signals
that you will use to form words with
your mouths pretty amazing it looks like
this oh wow language does it speak yeah
that's a minute language er you're like
that you would be so right now she was
gracious I'm using electrodes in my mind
right to create these sounds and move my
mouth in the way that it needs to move
in order for me to create these words
out of my mouth right and it's picking
up those signals and translating it into
like an audio clip - oh wow show me cuz
I don't know what the [ __ ] you just said
here everybody's gonna sound like a
Speak & Spell
it's not perfect but you'll see right
now the print that you are seeing is
Samuel bullying wounds that's really bad
right now cuz that French little bit
that sounds like Stephen Hawking yeah
yeah so it says the proof you are
seeking is not available in books so the
the book and the ship is not that great
so this person is speaking that right
now through the head through the yeah
just through their minds so this is the
people who are mute yeah so from what I
was mentioning earlier the people that
can't speak like when somebody's mute is
it born Muse because well I'm not sure
if you would know this is it because
there's something wrong with their vocal
cords or is it because of a mental block
that they can't I there's a lot of
different reason is reminding me of
those sex doll oh you know what I mean
have you heard their voices oh you don't
mean like it's like they sound like this
and I'm sure they have that inside of
them you know what I mean
those are creepy this reminds me of
conspiracy documentaries on YouTube you
click one and then it's like some Google
like voice and I'm like oh man I want a
real person that's so true though
they can be really disarming wait you
have one of them which one a sex doll
you do look like a lot of [ __ ] work
because you have to have this whole
thing like you might as well just
masturbate what's the day I have a sex
robot because I don't want to it's not a
robot a robot nothing but what if they
clean themselves it still doesn't matter
because it's still not a it's still not
a [ __ ] so what does it matter just
[ __ ] get your nut off and then relax
and then you go do it but what if you
want to have dinner with the first
absolutely would you put it in Lego
chair or something and like act like
it's a real person cuz like oh you can't
just like walk what sorry it's more like
a utilitarian thing for a guy sometimes
like somebody just got a [ __ ] nut
just to get your head clear yeah what if
the robots war I don't think about all
that sometimes actually I'm not just a
nut yeah exactly if the robot is warm
and it gets wet yep Wow
cuz some of that's watch out some robots
like jazz yep they can do different
voices so think you are technology's
gonna get better you can put different
wigs on them maybe it's maybe it's
because I'm not just a hyper sexual
person like I don't really need that
yeah yeah I'll be intimate with my
partner and that's great everything else
is just like no it's not Justin I just
be intimate my ankle socks are important
but those ankle socks dobra he likes the
little rubber grip at the end of it yes
so you asked me why people are born mute
or can't good question yeah so what I
found is that it's believed by some that
people are born without vocal cords but
that's not all
the case it seems to be that most of the
variations of being mute is like it's a
choice Hey almost like a psychological
thing yeah like a child that went
through trauma refused to speak they
just don't speak what about holder
though hold on get some people it's the
knurled so it's my anxiety yeah yeah
they're legion have 90% of children with
this disorder have been diagnosed with
social anxiety that's called selective
mutism there's all these other different
variations but anyway gosh
it sounds like a like a school paper
that you have to write you know what I
mean it's like a lot of research right
yeah I like it I like it I'm glad that
we can all speak I know
use your voice this channel would suck
overall mutes oh my god she interesting
how do we communicate in a sign language
maybe maybe what we would be in a chat
room chat sign language yeah I know why
we always want to communicate with each
other so I feel like if we were all mute
we could be it we could be a chat room
channel I mean they'll just watch us
chat do takes a lot of reading yeah I
know you better be a good reader yeah
you know I would I would fail I might
just like the gasps oh my god I'm here
at 5:00 yeah I thought it was gonna
really read the mind of I know their
time is they even sound like wonder if
there's like words you can't say cuz you
know how like on text you can't if
you're right [ __ ] it's like duck right
so it's like [ __ ] you and it's like not
you yeah I love spelling errors like
that it makes me feel really proud of
myself
[Laughter]
Georgian malformation for [ __ ] yeah but
they might program it so you can't cuss
at all it takes autocorrect thingy works
or I feel like reads your brain it might
actually read an image first so instead
of like a yellow duck it's like a penis
in a vagina all right it's supposed to
read your brain yeah yeah I'm reading
the movements that you create with your
mouth also you could still go like these
you're doing like that you're talking
but then that's coming up well when they
were
testing this out they were telling the
people like don't try to move your mouth
just think of how you're gonna move your
mouth oh it reminds me of drama school
we had to do so many like vocal
exercises like it's like using the
different parts of your mouth so go puff
and then go tit and then go cut do you
feel like it was the front of your mouth
the middle of your mouth in the back
open up your mouth yeah couldn't you
know project and all that mm-hmm
vocal exercises and then you you reverse
it got to yeah yeah I know I realize
that yeah that's like a baby
it does it we should that is harder it
is yeah
and then Peter Piper the pickled pepper
picker pick to pick up the bar scene
anyone do it can do do we do it I even
though the word Peter Piper picked up it
I don't know what the whole sake pickled
peppers did Peter Piper the pickled
pepper picker pick now Peter Piper
picked a peck of pickled peppers where's
the peck of pickled peppers that Peter
Piper difficult pepper picker picked
whoa like damn it you'll never make it
on Broadway I'm like I'm in LA so people
are saying that this is cool but it's
not a solution for everyone who cannot
communicate and also they're saying it's
not ready to be for the clinical trial
stuff it's not ready for that yeah I
want a real mind reader though I know
that would be so much more helpful what
am i psychic well that would be cool
yeah would you like it if it's real I
don't give a [ __ ] about what somebody
else is thinking
give you the winning model ticket number
that's Disney see now he's thinking
about conniving [ __ ] dude that's the
type of [ __ ] I want the superpower I
would want is the push one where you
push a thought into someone that one's
[ __ ] you want to be a good
manipulator yeah it's like minions dope
you could literally have everything that
you've ever wanted you can manipulate
everyone around you to get to where you
people do that in real life girl it's
called cult leaders media so there's a
call when this girl was like she creates
memories in your mind like for example
if I walk up to you and I'm the girl I
could make you believe that you're like
the father of my child in some [ __ ] I
don't know but like put put in same
memories into your mind I want to be
hypnotized
I've seen I was watching a bunch of
videos of people being hypnotized and I
want to be hypnotized yeah it's like
legit people are like hypnotize yourself
YouTube videos yeah who's gonna get me
out of it though yeah exactly
it doesn't work like how you think it
does it you gotta be said you got to be
you got to be wanting kind of okay yeah
yeah like if your wouldn't you know when
you watch a hypnotist or like those
those what-have-you illusion not
illusionist what do you call them it's
like a hypnotist anyways when you watch
those shows
they already hand-picked people that are
more suggestible to the hypnotizing and
they're like like the people that are
gonna go on stage and act like a dog or
a dog or whatever they already want to
do that [ __ ] exactly yeah they do it's
like they're they're out there they're
like oh this guy is gonna be funny it's
not gonna work I know skeptical ass yeah
see that's what sucks cuz I really
wanted to be like because you're just
being nudged toward a direction that you
already want to go there's no real mind
brainwashing or anything like that
they're they're kind of pushing you and
unlocking certain things and then you're
pretty much letting your real self come
out because most of us have this fake
persona
[Music]